How are you feeling now?
Good. Fine. Back at work.
What line of work are you in?
Waste management consultant.
The gangster is deeply ingrained in American cinema;
the gun-slinging badasses of the criminal underworld
have had enormous success since
their inception in the silent era.
But how is it that the American gangster, a character so violent,
profane, and cruel is so glorified on the
big screen? I want to explore a psycho-
analytic approach to this question and
see how the American gangster embodies
innate and universal human desires.
Let's start with a simple question: who
was the original gangster? Where did this
larger-than-life persona come from?
With this question you run into problems.
I personally consider Rico Bandello in
'Little Caesar' to be the first true
gangster. One of the first talking
gangsters, he's also the first to have
the iconic accent and distinct speech roll
now very familiar with. "Now, when I get in a tight spot
I shoot my way out of it. Why, sure,
shoot first and argue afterwards."
The problem is that he isn't really a gangster,
he's actually inspired to become a
gangster from a newspaper article about
Pete Montana to try to enter the
gangster world: He's a copycat. The very
first gangster film is 'The Musketeers of
Pig Alley' and the name of the film
originates from a newspaper article
about the shooting of a gambler on, quote:
"New York's Other Side". Perhaps the actual,
original depiction of gangsters was in a
collection of photographs of the slums
by Jacob Riis, with the famous photo
'Bandit's Roost' in 1890. The problem with
the gangster genre begins here
This photo is staged, Riis constructed the
shot to have its trademark level of fear
and fascination that we know and love
today and gangsters, and the influence of
this picture on the gangster genre is
seen up and into the 21st century.
This brings me to my first point: there
is no original gangster. Pretty much
every gangster we know and love is a
copycat. Michael Corleone's military
uniform and original distaste for gang
life borrows straight from Mike Powers
in 'The Public Enemy' and this shot in
pulp fiction eludes directly to 'The
Godfather'. Tommy's erratic behavior in
'Goodfellas' echoes Cody Jarrett in 'White
Heat', 'Scarface' is a remake, and even the
modern "hood" gangster doesn't completely
depart from conventional gangsters.
"They kept me in the hospital a week or so.
I mostly stayed up thinking about my cousin,
and watching old gangster movies."
"I've got to see some identification."
"How about my army discharge, I got it right here."
and of course the sopranos is famous for
referencing multiple gangster movies in
pretty much every episode. "Cheer me up,
babe." "Just when I thought I was out, they pull me back in."
Every iconic gangster movie is in some
way copycat-ing. "To make it, what was your
conversation with yourself, about how the
violence should be handled?" "Well, I,
I confess that I was very impressed
with Arthur Penn's 'Bonnie and Clyde' and uh..."
"I thought about that when watching, um, Sonny
Corleone get shot." "Without a doubt and I
thought that the the effects, the
depiction of violence in 'Bonnie and Clyde' always
had an imaginative twist to it." "...and I'd
like to think 'Goodfellas' comes out of
the tradition of something as
extraordinary as, as the roarin' twenties and 'Scarface'."
What's important to note here is that
every gangster borrows something from
older gangsters, and if you go back far
enough the gangster isn't based in
reality at all.
There's only the artificially constructed
idea of the gangster. This is a key point
in understanding America's obsession
with the Gangster. We're not actually
obsessed with being the leader of the
criminal underworld, we're obsessed with
what being a gangster represents. Now we
have to go back to the question at hand:
what does a gangster represent and why
do we like them so much? What is a gangster
even want? If you think it's just
money, or women then you're wrong.
"Oh, I ain't forgettin' all about the money." "Yeah, money's
all right but it ain't everything."
The best thing is, we can find out what a
gangster wants because they tell us.
"I don't want to be a product of my
environment. I want my environment to be
a product of me."
So what does that mean? That line
describes a desire that any human feels
and understands. If you watch any
gangster movie, each one has this similar
idea. "I don't want no dancin', l figure I'm makin' other people dance."
To understand
what this idea means, you have
to take a trip into the human psyche. I
point to a quote from psychologist Adam
Phillips:
when were angry it's
because something doesn't happen in the
way we wanted to. Even when you get mad
at something as simple as losing your keys,
it means your fantasy of an ideal world,
a world where everything is available to
you at your fingertips was disrupted. In
the ideal life the rest of the world
revolves entirely around you. "How would you
like to go walkin' in the dining room of the
Adolphus Hotel in Dallas, wearin' a nice
silk dress and have everybody waitin' on you?
Would you like that?"
The gangster is the perfect embodiment
of this fantasy. The world operates how
the gangster wants it to operate. He can
give orders with the twitch of his
fingers, when he walks in a room people
offer them a place to sit, to do
business all he has to do is nod.
This ability of the gangster transcends
simple money, or sex, or respect. It is the
idea that the gangster has complete
dominion over his world. "I'm gonnna make him
an offer he can't refuse." In 'The Godfather' what's the
first thing Vito Corleone asks? "Why did you go to the
police? Why didn't you come to me first?"
In this scene Amerigo Bonasera acts as
a threat to the gangster's all-powerful
reach. Bonasera goes to the police
first showing that he believes more in
the American justice system than in Vito.
Even the lighting has Bonasera's face
look like a rat making him visually
appear like a traitor. He doesn't buy into
the Godfather's power, but of course, the
Godfather wins him over.
In all of media, the
gangster is perhaps the closest
embodiment to a god. Superheroes come
close, but even they have to fight
villains and save the world.
Gangsters have nothing to worry about.
The appeal of the gangster is not that
he's a gangster, it's that he is
all-knowing and all-powerful. If he
doesn't want to pay the tab, he doesn't
have to. Imagine being able to live like
that. I think in the movies the worst
part about the gangsters downfall isn't
the actual death.
It's much worse than that. It's when the
gangster goes back to being just like us,
powerless and unable to control his
world. This idea goes as far back as 'The
Public Enemy', when the very physical and
expressive Tom Powers gets physically
restrained and mummified when he dies.
It's most present in 'Goodfellas', when
Henry Hill goes into witness protection program...
"Everybody had their hands out, everything
was for the taking... and now it's all over."
...and becomes just like you and me.  "I have to
wait around like everyone else."  And as he
closes the door we hear the sound of
jail cell bars closing, symbolizing his
loss of the all-powerful aura of the gangster.
Of course, I haven't mentioned one
crucial detail about the gangster: the
over-the-top violence. How's the genre so successful with such violence?
In one episode of 'The Sopranos' Tony takes his
daughter to visit colleges. On the way, he
recognizes a rat, hunts him down and
strangles the rat to death with a wire.
The creators of the show were hesitant
to make this episode because of its
hyper-violence, but made it anyway and
it's brutal.
The shots are extremely close up and it
follows the strangling to the bitter end.
The episode was praised by critics and
went on to win two Emmys, which begs
the question: why do we like this
horrific violence? The answer comes from
the idea of the taboo. Something taboo is
untouchable and there's a fascination
with things that cannot be touched.
Subjects like drugs and violence are
taboo, but the fact that they cannot be
touched gives them a level of power.
If you refuse to touch something then you
have to be, at some level, obsessed with it.
if that thing didn't matter to you, then
you wouldn't care if you touched it.
For some, the taboo is rooted in
superstition, like an aversion to Ouija
boards or black magic. With that
obsession comes a desire to observe the
taboo from a distance.
Naturally, there's a draw to look at
something that holds so much power over us.
"I know there are women like my best
friends, who would have gotten out of
there the minute their boyfriend gave
them a gun to hide. But I didn't. I gotta admit
the truth, it turned me on."
Speaking of rats, in Victorian society
they were inexplicably taboo. They were a
symbol of the unclean and were
certainly untouchable, but a sociologist
at the time wrote detailed accounts the
street performers who were trained in
handling and touching sewer rats.
Spectators would watch in disgust, but
also wonderment at the performers
ability to put his hand in a cage of
rats without getting bitten. That performer
in many ways had a mystical power to be
able to handle something that was so
taboo, and people "ooh'ed" in the crowd at
something they also found so repulsive,
and doesn't it sound a lot like the
gangster? Don't they have a certain power
to do things we would never have the
guts to do ourselves? By participating in
the taboo: sex, violence, and the criminal
life, they have an appeal to them, and the
distance between the movie screen and us
is the perfect amount of distance where
we get to observe - but not touch - the
taboo. The gangster is certainly a
complex character, but we're not all that
different from them. We all want that respect,
status, and control, the only difference
is we don't have the guts to do anything about it.
We're satisfied with seeing it on the
big screen, and maybe that's a good thing,
or maybe we're all a bunch of suckers
and they've been right all along.
"As far back as I can remember, I always wanted to be a gangster."
*Rags to Riches by Tony Bennet plays*
"I know I'd go from rags to riches.."
"...if you would only say you care."
"And though my pocket may..."